oh no question sodding basketball cut
football cuff up woman yeah yeah
start baseball don't stop baseball start
baseball
wait we know he said sports that's a
sport okay everybody I'm Ryan Chang this
is this is really this is where junior
and while playing stop benjoe marry or
kill [ __ ] cut stop benches three words
you can't remember or confuses the glade
the game this is like the witness
cross-examine when they make you
incriminate yourself you can take the
fifth just take the fifth with no Serena
starts that's easy I'm debating between
these two other
oh here's the issue I can get that ball
Tom Brady's only the greatest because
somebody caught the ball on the other
wow I could did it alone
everything Tiger did he did by himself
it's not a team sport
Syrena everything Sarina did she did
alone best friend so if you dominate by
yourself with no coach no other team
yeah this was easier than I thought
bench Tiger Woods cut Tom Brady oh no
question
starting basketball basketball way more
fun was we've seen a 50 NBA player keep
winning that actually teams would he
look like what it's not it's not a team
sport master dividual sport masquerade
she wasn't judas ankles broken right now
okay we we we agree to cut football
that's yeah let's just focus on we agree
on on guarantee track they're trying to
add again focusing on what we agree on a
baseball team has a 25 man roster it
employs more people nobody named one
came and name your teammates on baseball
you don't even know who they are I'm
getting money I don't need to know you
with your favorite team do you know I
worked at a restaurant when there was 40
people at the restaurant I know help we
was all getting money start basketball
cuz he crying and it is global I'll give
them that
that's the tiebreaker yeah oh oh okay
damn I want to say I wanted I want to
start Kyrie and Durant that seems like
an incredible duel i I hate to do this
but I'm going
the cut Stoudemire I'm sorry
starter my mellow oh no no no no okay
sorry I didn't know that was my long so
yeah I'm gonna cut me at one side of
mine sorry guys and then I'm gonna bench
kid and Vince just because for nostalgia
I know I know which one you gonna cut
I'm gonna stop museums you goggle Museum
before class they stole a bunch of [ __ ]
from other cultures it's all here in an
hour yeah and then the travel I'm gonna
bench it but not because I don't like
you travel you're on the team but just
cuz I had to pick one and I'm gonna cut
late nice stuff in New York because over
raided New York late night scene over
radio you can get anything you need in
this city you can't get anything 3:00 in
the morning anything at 3:00 a.m. after
10:00 p.m.
things are dead I know because I'm run
around New York City every night doing
stand-up comedy shows looking for places
to hang and only place I can find like a
7-eleven okay
so New York that's cuz you're not
invited to the cool places yeah okay
fine
hey this is my Chang and Roy Wood jr. we
just played stop bench cut on aisle
eight at start bench cut make sure you
watch us on the daily show for all of
your twenty20 election yeah stop the
Daily Show bench everyone else yeah